we're looking at maybe six to eight
weeks before we hit our peak and start
to come back down but we believe that if
people isolate and stay in groups of
under ten we believe if people avoid
non-essential travel we believe if
people stay home from work or telework
that those are all effective ways to
prevent the spread of virus we're
looking at South Korea we're looking at
Italy we're looking at everywhere cases
have popped up and again the scientists
feel very comfortable that these
mitigation efforts will have an impact
but they require cooperation they
require 50 to 70 percent of the country
really cooperating and doing their part
and that's what's most important right
now well there you've got the Surgeon
General on this program about 90 minutes
ago talking about isolating somebody who
knows exactly what that is like in South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham he's the
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee he's out of his self isolation
he got the test it was negative senator
for the people who are watching and
worried about this self isolation that
they're going through right now by not
being you know close to other people
what advice do you have for them because
it's so important that we do that well
what are we trying to accomplish here
America is under attack by a virus we're
moving to wartime footing how do you
kill the virus you deny human contact
the battle plan is no social gatherings
no eating out no school no sports
staying basically hunkered down in place
reduce work opportunity living off less
income that's how we kill the virus
unlike 9/11 where 1% of America has been
fighting the terrorists a hundred
percent of us are foot soldiers in its
battle so if you're out of work the
Congress is going to try to give you a
paycheck not a one time check the
unemployment insurance system never
envisioned everybody being unemployed at
one time the Small Business
Administration never envisioned all the
small businesses needing loans so this
package we're working on called phase
three is designed in my view to give
people income to get through this okay
senator so many people at home don't
understand everything that's going on in
Washington we've heard phase
one we've heard phase two now you're
mentioning phase three we've heard the
defense production act Chuck Schumer has
a plan when you tell us what what's
gonna happen who's gonna benefit from
all of this if you're out of work you
need pay so here's what I'm working on
with Democrats in South Carolina you can
apply for unemployment insurance the
maximum pavement is three hundred twenty
six dollars Ainsley before taxes that's
not nearly enough to get through this
you may be hunkered down for six to
eight weeks maybe even longer so what if
the federal government supplemented
unemployment insurance payments all over
the country I'm willing to pay 75% of
people's income up to $80,000 to get us
through that this this ought to be
enough money to get us through this next
six to eight weeks senator I think
that's you got to raise that threshold a
little bit because I know for couples
154 Ike singles 75 I mean if you make a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars you
take home about ninety you have three
kids I believe that they have to be
addressed to middle-class matters yeah
the family unit I mean the bottom line
here is that we're trying to restore
people's income before the virus you had
an income right if you weren't working
your own unemployment or your own
welfare after the virus
you're not working I want to restore
your income I don't want to give you a
thousand dollars and say good luck I
want an income stream it either comes
from your employer I'm willing to lend
let every employer in the country borrow
money to make payroll as long as they do
payroll now I'm willing to increase
unemployment benefits so you get most of
your check
senator Gramm you know what is going on
right now in Washington is something
that we haven't actually seen happen
much over the last couple of years and
that is you're talking to Democrats
Democrats are talking if the Republicans
stuff is getting done this is what
everybody in America needs you to do
right now and it looks like you're right
you know Congress is rising to the
occasion
yeah the impeachment debacle has been
replaced by the spirit of 9/11 I think
America is under attack this under
attack by a virus that can be destroyed
if we stay away from each other the
virus needs human contact
all of this social distancing distancing
staying out of school not going out the
is going to kill the virus over time but
Republicans and Democrats have one
mission in Phase three in my view is to
make sure that you get most of your
income if not all of it most of it and
how do you do that you can do it through
loans to businesses you can do it do it
through the unemployment insurance
system but we have to work together like
people are at home and I think they get
that Center I got to ask you there's a
story in The Washington Post today that
Jared Kushner is running a parallel
relief plan with the vice-president
they're on separate tracks and working
against each other not on the same page
you talked to the President as much as
anyone is this in fact true it would be
news to me this is a wartime president I
talked to him last night he is going to
try to come up with a battle plan to
kill the virus as soon as possible and
help the economy stabilize until we get
through this I haven't seen any inviting
personally but we're at war we're at war
with a virus and here's the good news
you can kill this virus if you just stay
away from each other is it acceptable
for them to be working on separate paths
it's unacceptable for any of us to be
working in different paths you got
Democrats and Republicans what do you
got you got constituents out of work
what do you do with people have lost
their job in Myrtle Beach Ainsley you
give them a paycheck what do you do to a
small business that has no customers you
give them a loan so they can get through
this and you can forgive the loan later
all of us should be about income
stability you got a lot on your plate at
home right now you just lost your job
I'm gonna do everything I can to make
sure in the next 48 hours or 72 hours
you find a way to replace your income do
you know what the president's message is
at 11 o'clock today
I think somebody very optimistic there's
three things to look for here the day we
have fewer cases in one week versus the
other that's turning the corner
therapies today they come online to
reduce mortality that's turning the
corner when a vaccines on the horizon
that will be turning the corner when
those three things begin to happen we'll
turn the corner I think at 11 o'clock
you're going to hear some optimistic
news about therapies and
ments to save people's lives but until
then followed the battle-plan right stay
at home you did stay at home when you
were self isolating somebody down at
mar-a-lago for the people who are
isolating right now do you have any
advice on how to pass the time because
it's driving some people crazy yeah I
watched up the crown I watched the
Vietnam War I watched a lot of things I
stated I stayed on the phone we're going
to get to know each other well we like
it or not but compare this to World War
two we had blackouts we had most of our
sons and daughters going off to foreign
lands to get killed this is not that
kind of commitment it is a serious
moment in American history to defeat the
virus all you have to do is stay at home
and make sure that if you get sick
you're responsible about it
that is so well put Lindsey Graham's
always good to see you
thank you